[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous je m'appelle
l honneur bonsoir moi c est l pour être
honnête avec vous il y a une fille mais
nous étions devant une feuille blanche
et on se demandait mais comment on
allait vous parler de l'amour
pourquoi tedx fribourg nous a choisis
nous deux femmes fribourgeoise qui se
sont connus sur les bancs du collège de
saint-michel et qui se soucie de
construire un avenir durable
nous avons tous quelque chose à dire sur
l'amour vous public pour y être sur
cette scène ce soir à notre place et
nous parler de votre amour et de votre
passion l'amour pour le vin l'amour pour
les cloches l'amour pour l'air pour les
livres pour le foot
ou alors pour la planète finalement nous
avons tous quelque chose en nous qui
nous allume pour nous l'amour c'est une
sensation inconditionnels qui a ni figé
dans le temps et qui a ni défi
précisément définie mais qui a seize
années par des ingrédients secrets dont
nous sommes à la recherche
dès nos premiers jours jusqu'à notre
dernier souffle et il ya maintenant à
peu près deux ans notre recherche s'est
intensifiée il nous manquait ces petites
choses qui nous font vibrer vous savez
justement ces ingrédients secrets qui
forment cette sensation de bonheur et
d'amour qui apparaissent à des moments
donnés et qui disparaissent on avait
vécu des moments signifiant dans notre
vie la perte d'un proche un travail dans
lequel on ne sait pas lui c'est plus une
santé qui se dégrade elle est un amour à
sens unique et on vous dit sincèrement à
ce moment-là il pense qu'on a touché le
fond mais on a remarqué que c'était une
opportunité une opportunité pour créer
une force positif qui nous sortirait de
cette déséquilibre on appris
on a laissé parler la tristesse on a
laisser surgir la colère on est allé à
la rencontre de nos peurs pour
comprendre le pourquoi et on a pris
conscience du chemin parcouru on a pris
conscience des moments de bonheur
on a pris conscience de la valeur de la
vie et on a surtout pris le pouvoir sur
les choses qui nous faisait qui ivre et
ceci pas à pas geste après geste et
parfois il faut reculer pour tout voir
avancer c'est comme le tir à l'arc
c'est peut-être ça l'ingrédient secret
est donc le 20 mai 2017 est élément
sediba il faut qu'on prenne du temps
pour qu'on prenne du recul
donc on s'est vu on a pris une feuille
blanche et s'est assise et on a réfléchi
à toutes ces choses qui nous définissent
vraiment ce que vous voyez sur cette
feuille c'est moi comme par exemple le
mot indépendance
le fait de créer quelque chose de ses
propres mains
le respect de nos valeurs connaître ses
vraies valeurs et vivre en cohérence et
en harmonie avec elle
l'environnement prendre soin de la vie
et de son habitat
le free geisst avoir un esprit libre et
ouvert et finalement l'épanouissement le
fait de faire les choses par amour cette
feuille en fait c'est le point de départ
de notre projet et ça vraiment cette
feuille est en fête avec estelle on
s'est rendu compte en faisant ça petit
exercice comportait en ou le projet
depuis un petit moment
à travers notre enfance notre jeunesse
l'expérience le chemin qu'on a parcouru
on s'est rendu compte qu'on avait déjà
ce projet en nous et en fait il fallait
simplement le mettre en mouvement et de
passes et de cette feuille à l'action
trouver son nid qui gueulent un concept
japonais qui se traduit
par le sens la raison d'être la raison
de se lever le matin avec un sourire sur
les lèvres
le fait de ressentir cette joie de vivre
cet amour pour tout ce qu'on entreprend
c'est en fait un équilibre entre notre
passion notre mission notre profession
est notre vocation est donc en cherchant
cette éthique et c'est ti gars on est
allé au plus profond de nous-mêmes et on
a réfléchi à ce qui nous définit
vraiment et pour nous d'avoir trouvé ce
qu'ils gagnent s'est traduit par un
projet mettant au centre l'écologie
l'écologie vient du grec
oikos qui signifie maison et habitat et
leurs gosses qui signifie discours
l'écologie étudie les relations de
dépendance est les interrelations entre
eux et leur milieu de vie et étudie en
fait le fonctionnement de la terre et
nous êtres humains en faisant partie
intégrante de cet écosystème et dans nos
recherches dans notre apprentissage de
notre cheminement écologique
nous avons remarqué qu'on crée un
véritable déséquilibre
un déséquilibre qui est social politique
économique est surtout écologique
un vrai problème systémique
[Musique]
ah ben ouais
non stop
vous vous sentez comment démunis
angoissé perdu face à cette réalité pour
nous on avait une émotion d'impuissance
face à cette réalité et je le pense
souvent on le pense souvent parce qu'on
n'a pas simplement être ces écrans on
aurait pris une autre voiture qu'on a
peut-être on serait allé faire du
shopping et puis aller boire un bon
script ce pour quoi on a continué à se
battre et c'est grâce à la honte pour un
monde plus respectueux les justes et
surtout plus équilibré qu'on a décidé
d'agir qu'on a décidé d'agir et donc le
20 mai l'autre nom le 31 mai 2018 à peu
près une année après estelle et moi on a
décidé de créer notre association et on
l'a nommé de green jobs
la goutte verte vers green et hop la
ville à l'association en fait a pour but
principal de sensibiliser la population
fribourgeoise à l'importance de réduire
son impact environnemental et surtout
d'initier un changement de comportement
vers un mode de vie plus durable et plus
éco responsable
la philosophie de l'association elle
s'appuie sur la philosophie des petits
gestes la philosophie que nous vivons
chaque jour le fait de réfléchir et
d'agir pas à pas geste après geste nous
permet en fait de ne pas se sentir
complètement démunis et découragés face
à l'immensité de l'océan et ceci se
traduit aussi dans une grille à
coresponsable la philosophie chaque
goutte compte c'est en fait que chaque
geste entrepris par l'être humain dans
le respect de l'environnement un impact
sur la nature et surtout un impact sur
l'entourage social et d'avoir gardé
cette philosophie en tête nous à nous a
aidés à ne pas désespérer et surtout à
ne pas tomber dans un trou d'impuissance
et c'est devenu notre conscience
écologique qui est devenue une autre
ide dans tout ce qu'on entreprend et
c'est peut-être ça l'ingrédient secret
on pense également à un autre ingrédient
secret qui nous a permis d'avancer le
partage le fait d'échanger et le partage
se marie très bien avec l'amour le
partage et inconditionnelle sans retour
sans attente et on se souvient avec
estelle au début de notre cheminement
écologique de tous les échanges qu'on a
eues avec les acteurs du changement
écologique qui nous ont enrichi et qui
nous ont permis de grandir et ses
acteurs écologique avait déjà fait leur
bout de chemin
il avait déjà abouti à des projets éco
responsable et partagé avec eux ça a été
en fait une véritable expérience on a
grandi ensemble et on a regardé dans la
même direction
et dans cette approche on sait jamais
demandé quel était le profit pour nous
mais plutôt le profit pour la nature et
l'environnement et peut-être c'est ça
l'ingrédient secret il ya une autre
chose une autre approche
qu'en pense que c'est une force pour
nous c'est notre complicité qui a grandi
dès le début quand on s'est connus sur
les bancs du collège saint michel est
cette complicité elle a grandit chaque
jour chaque jour on devait arrosé
chacune de notre côté on a pleuré
ensemble on a beaucoup rigolé elle s'est
en fait ça le plus beau apprentissage
humain c'est de se respecter soi-même et
après de respecter l'autre et des le
preuve dès le début de notre projet on a
senti une énergie à une force
inexplicable de lutter pour un futur
durable et on pense sincèrement que
c'est grâce à l'amour qui a sonné par
ces petites ingrédients secrets de
prendre du recul de connaître ses vraies
valeurs de partage et et d'avancer pas à
pas cette définition de l'amour est
quelque chose qui n'est pas figée dans
le temps
chacun d'entre nous a une manière
différente de définir l'amour ce qui est
primordial c'est de toujours
restait à la recherche de cette
définition à la recherche de ces
ingrédients secrets à la recherche de
son nid qui gagnent à la recherche de
son moteur de vie et du sens même que
nous voulons donner à notre vie si vous
vivez dans un déséquilibre avec estelle
on pense vraiment que la première chose
que vous devez faire c'est d'abord
identifier l'inconfort dans lequel vous
êtes
avant de vouloir en sortir prendre du
recul et prendre du temps pour soi et ce
soir on a décidé de vous faire faire un
petit exercice avec une pour vous mettre
en condition donc asseyez vous
confortablement sur votre chaise
mettez vos deux pieds par terre pour
sentir le sol
fermez les yeux et respirez profondément
trois fois avec nous
pensez à ce que vous aimez penser à ce
pourquoi vous êtes doué penser à ceux
dont le monde a besoin est peut-être ce
soir quand vous rentrez chez vous prenez
une feuille blanche
remettez-vous en condition et
réfléchissez à ce qui vous définit
vraiment ce soir en partage notre
philosophie avec vous on partage notre
histoire avec vous mais on ne sait pas
ce qui vous arrive dans votre vie on
peut pas être prouvée vos émotions
on sait pas ce qui vous est arrivé
aujourd'hui mais en fait c'est vraiment
un simple partage qui en espère qu'ils
vous motivera qui vous inspirent à à
faire le pas osé faire le pas osez vous
jeter à l'eau car par amour tout est
possible pour retrouver ce sentiment de
cohérence et d équilibre et au final
c'est peut-être ou l'ingrédient secret
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]